I make blasts Cline miles and I make
cloth Klein dongs fabric Klein bottles
are fit on your head if you start taking
this inside-out
I noticed though you pull it inside out
and keep going keep going keep going
eventually you get a shape that remember
this is the same as the same model where
the fabric is going in one direction and
the other direction there's a circular
hole where my finger touching this part
of the manifold is going the left this
finger is going to the right so there's
a round hole around here okay I looked
at that and I said I'll bet that that's
related to what in topology is called a
cross cap I looked at and I said okay
that's nice to know
so one day I'm over here doing the
laundry three check this up so I'm doing
the laundry one day and I reach in and
pull out my jeans
well my jeans see a lot of service and I
pull it out and I look at the pants like
and well there's a hole in the knee I
know that I'll keep wearing it but the
pants leg has pulled through its hole so
that it goes up along here and down
along here no words if I had it the
right way out if I hadn't been pulled
inside out it'd be just an ordinary
pants leg well the hole in it but popped
out of the dryer looking like this
and I looked at it and said wait a
second this shape here where one side is
going this way this side is going this
way it's the same fabric shape as a head
with this okay
so I said
hey I could probably make a claim bottle
out of this pants leg all I have to do
is cut it across here and bring it
around and sew it together okay so I
start with this cut off the leg right
there so now I have a pant leg with a
hole in the knee in this funny shape
what I'm calling a cross cabin I think
it's a topological cross gap all I have
to do is bring this around into a fellow
seem to get this I now have a this hole
has got to be the same as this hole this
pathway up here is the same as this
pathway up here this is a denim Klein
bottle that you can make and the way to
make it if you don't want to use denim
is you say okay find a shirt or a pair
of pants so you have a shirt that's you
know your usual J random shirt and start
by cutting the sleeve off cut the sleeve
along here now I have the ingredients
for a Klein bottle there is the hole
that was in the sleeve the cuff I'll
bring this bring the cuff through the
hole I now have that interesting cross
cap going up this way going down this
way bring these around so that the
shoulder part is sewn to the cuff and
that'll make
a Klein bottle so this is the way if you
want a Klein bottle out of an old shirt
you don't have to come to Klein bottle
dot-com and buy this you don't have to
go get a Klein bottle hat it at my
website save you money save me time and
recycle an old shirt into a topological
manifold
you can get to Klein bottles out of
every old church you got and another
pair of Klein bonds out of every pair of
pants is that a deal or what and yes
there are Klein bottles in here